let's start with the the hockey world uh
eddie um
let's start uh with what you think of
what's going on in the bubble
and how you think no fans is affected or
no i guess home ice advantage how you
think that has affected the way that
things have played out for lord
stanley's cup so far
well full disclosure i'm currently in
quarantine in the edmonton bubble right
now
i just got here a couple of days ago so
i have a couple more days of quarantine
and
meaning i can't leave my room they come
and test me every every day once a day
and
once i am cleared then i'll be able to
get amongst the the
nhl family here in the bubble and be
able to get to work and do the
oaks coverage and derby coverage for us
and also the hockey coverage but as far
as the games i
honestly rich i mean i think they've
been i think they've been very
entertaining
i i think the uh the understanding is
that yeah
there are no fans but as a player and
having played in the league as long as
they did for 16 years is you know no
disrespect to the
light i think are the best fans in all
the sports is that
when you're playing you're really not
hearing you're not thinking you're not
you know you're
you're not wandering right you don't
know you're just playing the only time
you know there's fans is after either
something happens or you're sitting on
the bench and
you're looking into an empty arena or
what have you so i think the mental
challenge for all of these sports not
only the national hockey league but for
the wnba the nba
major league baseball you know whatever
else we got going on soccer is that
it's that uh you know understanding that
you got a job to do but also respecting
and knowing that we got a lot going on
in the real world and
we're here to entertain and that's for
us as broadcasters as well but i think
for the most part
the games have been pretty pretty darn
good i think they've been entertaining i
think that
the teams are are all in and uh we get
we're down to
you know we're down to seven we're down
to seven teams right now and the
three three the four series uh were on
the brink
and uh all those teams staged off uh
elimination and now we're gonna have a
bunch of game sixes so
all in all i think it's been pretty good
and oh by the way a tip of the hockey
helmet to the national hockey league
they've done an amazing job in both
bubbles in toronto and in edmonton and
the leadership of the commissioner mr
bettman bill daley the deputy
commissioner the board of governors the
players the players association return
to play committee and all the medical
people
that are helping us go through uh it's
been uh it's been amazing to be
to see what's taking place and i think
hockey fans have been entertained and at
the end of the day rich that's that's
what we all want
best team left in the bubbles is fill in
the blank
i would probably say tampa
not knowing the injury to nikita
kucharov who
you would argue is their best player uh
he got hurt the other night
uh in game five against boston took his
air and stick from zadino chara so
but the way that they've played they
have been able to play
a hard game a game that's uh
you know tight checking but also they've
been able to play rich to take a game
where
they can play the skill game and in in
and dictate
that type so uh they've gotten great
goaltending from andre vasilevskiy who
is one of the best goalies in the league
so
right now uh i would have to say the
tampa bay lighting
okay and uh which which team uh in the
west
which one do you take
well i thought dallas was the sleeper at
the start of the regular season prior to
the pause
right um they didn't start off very well
but they've kind of found their game
here and yes they've probably taken
advantage of an opportunity
with colorado and their goaltending
situation
uh they're losing eric johnson uh big
defenseman so they're up three to two
they had to miss
they missed an opportunity to end the
series the other night so now they have
a game
huge game six tonight um
i mean vegas you know vegas looks like
they are they're the most complete team
now they lost last night and got out
goaltended
they shouldn't say they got out
goaltended i mean patrick demko the
vancouver canucks just
you know he played out of his mind and
his first playoff start had 43 shots on
goal and stopped 42 of them so
vegas probably deserved a little bit
better when i but i look at the
overall picture you know vegas looks to
be the
the team that maybe just has it above
everybody else in the west but
uh i thought dallas would give everybody
a run and
uh you know they're on the they're you
know they're on the verge of going to
the conference final so
don't underestimate the dallas stars
they're pretty good as well and we'll
see
if it's philly or the islanders uh
we can join uh the lightning and then
tonight again on nbc sn
at eight eastern time we'll see if
dallas can close out colorado or the
avalanche can
i guess pull a denver nuggets um and
forcing game seven here you know
see if they can uh take some inspiration
from uh from the local basketball team
there eddie ulcek joining
joining us i guess let me ask you a
question about the bubble
portal entry portal uh literally you are
in your hotel room you may not leave it
that is essentially what is happening
right now uh that is that is the uh that
is the protocol for anybody that
um comes into the bubble and it's four
straight days
of uh you know uh in your room
and uh just doing what you need to do
and look thankfully for me
i mean you know it's it's derby week so
um yes
um i'm up to my ears horse racing and
i'm also
up to my ears and keeping you know
what's going on and the national hockey
league so
um lots of uh lots of his time i just
became a grandfather over the course of
the
pandemic so i'm very proud of that my
daughter my granddaughter audrey marie
ulcek was born on july the 7th so my son
eddie and my daughter-in-law erica are
proud parents and we get to i get to see
my granddaughter
uh all the time and uh especially now
with me being away so it makes
me it helps pass the time there was a
nice way to wake up today when my
my son and my daughter-in-law called me
and there was my granddaughter on the
other end of uh
on the on the fifth time so that was
really cool so yeah look at hey
it's what it is look at and we
understand and i understand
what's going on in the real world
absolutely 100
and um it's part of the protocol to keep
everybody safe and look at i think the
league has had
don't quote me i think they've had like
30 000 tests now in the course of the
first five weeks that they've been in
the bubble or six weeks and
uh you know they're perfect so whatever
they're doing they're doing it right and
uh i'll i'll be i'll be let out of my
room on friday and then you'll be full
board
there'll be four full bore of pucks and
ponies on the weekend for eddie
that's about to say you're going to be
like coming out of the gate like like a
thoroughbred like
he'll be bucking and you'll be bucking
behind that door when he when he can
follow up but very important question
then
he's bucking and squealing that's right
exactly it's very important question
before we move on to the horses
is there at least a minibar in that room
well you're talking to somebody that is
only uh i don't even know if drank is
the right word but i've only tried three
times in my life but you know no
no no eddie i was not talking about that
i literally was like toblerone like
you know i mean like like some snacking
you know what i mean you know what rich
you know what i'm going i'm gonna go
through all these drawers right now
while you got me on the air here let's
do it what do you got eddie i'm gonna
tell you what i got here okay guys
um so let's see i got the the holy book
here okay that's that's good that i have
okay what else i have
i have an ion i have a i have a safe for
really i have no reason because my wife
has all my money i do have everything
okay and uh let's see and i have a nice
rope here at the uh it's a nice marriott
so that's other than that rich
other than that that's all i got oh my
god they locked the door i mean
edmonton marriott i mean okay
listen take the robe and put it on the
rich eisen show okay
we'll send that up the peacock flowchart
i might want to take this
uh this ottoman i got in a room here
very good with that on expensive the
ottoman senators everybody hey now
that's a little bit of a dad joke hockey
pun to move us through
or dave ottoman or david
that's scary and i don't look i have no
excuse i'm not in a bubble i've just
lost my mind
so let's move to the to the ponies here
uh eddie ulcek here on the rich eisen
show
uh tis the law three to five uh we're
assuming is that an appropriate odds
uh for this horse he's gonna this horse
is gonna
repeat what do you think what do you got
for me well i mean i think three to five
would be generous if you could lock that
in right now i don't think he's gonna be
three to five i think he's gonna be less
than that just because people
know his history and the resume i mean
he's won six or seven career races now
the only race he did not win was at
churchill downs but now that was on a
sloppy track supposed to be beautiful
weather and move along
on saturday so i mean look at he is
he is good uh the horse that i like
going into the derby unfortunately had
the scratch because of a foot injury art
collector look for him in the preakness
in about
what is that about four or five weeks
from now rich art collector looks like
uh a horse that people should be okay
notice of so look at if you're in the if
you're in the
you know making wagers on favorites look
at um i'm all for that look at if you
want to invest five dollars
and get back seven uh some people don't
mind that if you want to add a zero to
that then you know hey
eddie let me let me just interrupt you
we are not interested in that
we are absolutely uninterested
thoroughly in that
uh what what can you tell hold on hold
on a second
decided to bet 5 000 to win on them and
you got back 7
000 total that's i mean that's a pretty
good return on money in a matter of
about two minutes and two seconds
making two grand on your money well in
two minutes
let me interrupt you right there i am
thoroughly uninterested in that too
so let's find the the the nice middle
okay between betting five grand
i'll just say this for for you uh for
your fandom there
yes i am not gonna pick tis the law to
win the derby like i will be
like it's probably gonna be 99.8 percent
of the people out there
are going to kiss the law i can't pick a
horse two to five in an 18 horse field
okay um but i'll tell you i'm looking to
a horse that i think in the morning line
is 30 to one
is coming out of post position number
three the name of the horse is
enforceable
uh of course a hockey guy likes
enforceable come on
we all feel a little taller and a little
stronger when we have some enforcers
around us yeah um
enforceable is a horse that is not going
to be in the picture early
meaning he's not going to be near the
front probably going to be sitting
i don't know maybe 12 13 14
in the race i think the horse can get
the mile and a quarter distance a lot of
these horses haven't run our mile and a
quarter some have including towards the
law so he is
proven at the distance but i'm going to
love the value of the sword i think it's
going to get every bit of 30 to 1 on
this horse and look at
even if you want to just put the horse
put some money on this horse across the
board meaning win place or show all the
horse has to do
is finish first second and third and
you're probably gonna triple or
quadruple your money
if the horse happens to finish third but
i think the race is going to set up
nicely for him now is he classy enough
is he good enough
he's stepping into the major leagues um
time will tell but i think there's
enough
uh good things that can happen for him
in this race to make a run
and uh and maybe i'll get a little
excited at the eighth pole and maybe the
three horse will come
running and move them all down at 30 to
one and uh hopefully people will be able
to cash in so look at you
whether you want to use this horse is a
win bed or a place or a show
that's one thing but i would suggest
using them in your
exact is meaning your top two finishes
or your trifecta
i think the three has been training well
if you had a much better post position
than he's had the last couple of races
so
i said i'm gonna take a shot here but
i'm going to put i'm going to put a few
bucks on the three horse enforceable to
win the 146th running
of the kentucky dirt all right now when
you say trifecta that means there's a
third horse so let's just say somebody's
like okay tis the law
is going to win and uh so a 17-5
and then you trifecta what are we again
and this
is just this is just you know for you
know watson giggles uh
you know yeah yeah exactly i'm gonna
have this here at all
right how about this i'm going to be out
of the bubble and i'll be in the arena
in edmonton
uh calling doing the horse racing from
edmonton alberta canada and calling
and getting picks in louisville all
right let me i'll give you some numbers
here you got to use a three enforcement
another long shot i think you should use
is the 15 new york traffic
okay the six the 16 horse honor ap
and the 17 tis the law so if you're back
to 3
15 16 17 any combination of those
four horses three uh
you know you're gonna you know you're
gonna make your money and then some
because those are a couple of horses new
york traffic
and enforceable are gonna be every bit
of you know probably north of 25 and 30
to one so
now the key is is that tis the law
finishes
third and then if you can get those
other three horses in the top two
then you're gonna get really get paid so
if you invest maybe 12
or 24 dollars in that wager you might
turn that if the numbers come up right
you might
turn the twenty four dollars into maybe
six or seven hundred there you go
i'm glad you didn't say the 50 to one
south bend because it's a michigan
wolverine i just couldn't do it i
couldn't do it
i'm glad you did i'm glad you left south
bend out of it and i'll be very honest
with you
just for people that know real quick uh
king guillermo who is going to be the
four or
five he is the sixth horse king
guillermo is old i don't know if you
know this
rich is owned by victor martinez former
major league all-star and uh
great hitter for the clevelanders yeah
he owns king caramel he's only been
horse racing
or i want to say just less than the last
maybe eight or ten months but he's got
himself a uh
this horse gonna run good you're gonna
think you're gonna hear the name king
guillermo okay
uh early in this race i don't know if he
can go that far and he's been off i
think for almost four or five months but
uh
just a little sports story there that uh
victor martinez owns uh
owns the uh uh four or five the six
horse kings
love it ed thanks for the call
appreciate you spending some time in the
edmonton bubble with us but i i mean
what's more 2020
uh eddie ulcek than saying that you're
in the edmonton bubble
to get ready for conference finals
action in a pandemic for the nhl
while covering the kentucky derby that's
normally held the saturday after the nfl
draft now it's the saturday before the
nfl season
but that's that's 20 20 for you right
there rich stay safe and uh you know
what let's
let's just get on the right side of this
and uh everybody stay safe out there and
look forward to
talking to you soon yeah absolutely well
let's talk the next couple of weeks as
uh as we're getting set for for the nhl
stanley cup final that's eddie ulcek
joining us from the edmonton bubble
right here on the rich eisen show and
nbc you like that video of course you
did
check out more right here